as pro lockdown leftists get shriller in
their calls to lock everyone at home
from coast to coast everyone from cops
to judges to ordinary people are wising
up to the simplest way to stop them call
their bluff just weeks after premises
own lockdown or to run saving just one
life New York Governor Andrew Cuomo is
promising that lots of grannies are
going to die what a difference two
months and a lot of failed policies
makes and the gaslighting me to movement
is now pretending they never told us to
believe all women do they think that we
don't have Google all that [ __ ] Michael
knows and this is the Michael knows Joe
[Music]
a lot of people calling their bluff in
this country and I sure do love it you
know I am in Los Angeles in California
which is the most outrageous
overreaching city in the most outrageous
overreaching state in the entire country
in there parts of New York that are
opening up much more quickly than Los
Angeles even though LA has practically
no cases of coronavirus and obviously
New York and other places have a lot
more where you are right now please let
me know in the comments section are
things reopening is the government you
know taking the foot off the gas pedal
or is it getting worse as it doubling
down is it remaining the same is it
another three or four months I can't
tell if LA is just the complete outlier
or not here it sure does feel like it
out here in California but I'd like to
know your experience of it too because
around the country a lot of citizens are
just saying now we're not going to put
up with it and guess what the powers
that be are folding like a deck of cards
we will get into all of that first
though I have got to thank our friends
over at NetSuite you know right now with
this level of economic uncertainty
businesses need systems that give them
complete visibility into their numbers
the last few months have taught us
what's important in life and it's taught
us what we need to eliminate or change
it's the same for business what are the
changes that you need to make all you
need is NetSuite by Oracle the world's
number one at cloud business system
finance HR inventory ecommerce
everything you need all in one place so
that you save time money and headaches
especially now at any time it's
important to know your numbers in your
business but especially especially right
now join over 20,000 companies who trust
NetSuite to go faster with confidence
right now receive your free guide
perfect time to read it to seven actions
businesses need to take now and schedule
your free product or at NetSuite comm
slash Knowles canna wles get your free
guide schedule your free product tour
right now NetSuite comm slash Knowles
NetSuite dot-com slash Knowles canna
wles
I just saw my favorite video that I've
seen on the Internet in many many weeks
this comes out of Camden New Jersey so
the Democratic governor of New Jersey
Phil Murphy is pushing pretty heavy
draconian lockdown measures not just
reasonable measures to allow two people
to protect their own public health but
but they're really onerous measures here
and the people of Camden just don't want
to hear it anymore so they decide
they're gonna start reopening the cops
get called to the reopening and we're
not by the way they're not reopening
businesses like a hundred percent right
away there was a gym in Camden that
opened at just 20 percent capacity and
they had a bunch of other extra
coronavirus precautions in place they
had fever checks at this gym you want to
go work out you got to get your
temperature taken before you you walk in
so these people are being very cautious
very responsible still the cops get
called to the gym to shut it down but
one cop wasn't having it you know there
was a big crowd of people around at the
gym and the cop walked up he said
technically you're all in violation of
the law but have a nice day normally you
are all in violation of the executive
orders well you hang out on that note
have a good day
I love this guy we need to get this cop
a Medal of Freedom this is such the
right attitude a lot of our system of
government is premise tahn the idea that
various branches various departments
various levels will push back on the
others and we will avoid tyranny because
everybody has got these sort of more
local interests a different
understanding of different communities
and so you can you can push back on
things and that's exactly what this cop
did absolutely terrific stuff you see in
California these ridiculous cops chasing
a paddleboarder around in the middle of
the ocean paddleboarders not near
anybody and the cops are trying to chase
him down on boards and boats and things
like that
obviously absurd in New Jersey the cop
walks up because look everybody's being
very safe you've got masks on you're a
twenty-percent
you're taking people's temperatures you
couldn't possibly be more responsible
technically you're in violation of this
dumb law but have a nice day the
Governor of New Jersey didn't like that
much Murphy said quote I'm not concerned
it will spiral out of control and we
will take action if you show up at that
gym again tomorrow there's going to be a
different reality than showing up today
these aren't just words we've got to
enforce this but I also don't want to
start World War three okay
all right pal I think your threats are a
little bit empty because what the what
this cop showed what those people who
were protesting the lockdown showed is
that especially in a democratic republic
the politicians can't lead people where
they don't want to go and there's a
whole lot of bluster and there's a whole
lot of power grabbing going on but
ultimately these politicians are still
in many ways accountable so the people
look at the phrasing that the governor
uses it's going to be different tomorrow
these aren't just words it's not that
he's worried about protecting public
health he it's that he's worried about
losing credibility and I think that's
true for a lot of the overreaching
politicians here all of their
predictions have not come true we
haven't come close to overwhelming the
health care system we've we've social
distance we've done all these policy
is virtually perfectly and the
prediction models haven't come true and
there's no end to them in sight
all right the We the People have upheld
our end of the bargain remember 15 days
to slow the spread we did it we did it
we stayed at home we abided by these
policies right and yet
day by day it seems clearer and clearer
that the policies have had very little
if any effect at all and day by day it's
clearer and clearer that the timetable
that we were told we had to use these
policies is being extended constantly we
held up our end of the bargain the
politicians and the labcoat dictators
did not hold up their end of the bargain
we the people who predicted that maybe
this isn't going to turn out the way the
doomsdayers are saying it will we the
people who were a little bit skeptical
about this whole thing turned out to be
right and the lab coat hysterics and the
politicians who insisted out those
outsourced our entire politics to them
turned out to be wrong
and now we've had enough so we're gonna
push back and you know what those guys
are gonna do in their state capitals and
in their lab coats they're gonna do
absolutely nothing about it because
ultimately they don't have nearly as
much power as they want to pretend that
they do this is happening in New Jersey
this is happening on the other coast in
California at last Friday a great town
in California out water California voted
to declare itself a sanctuary city for
businesses you know in California we
have a lot of sanctuary cities for
illegal aliens who violate some of our
most basic laws vary just laws vary the
key aspects of our Constitution the idea
that we the people can decide who comes
and goes out of our states and out of
our country
so we have those kind of sanctuary
cities here but apparently we're not
allowed to have sanctuary cities for
people who want to be able to leave
their homes and have an economy that
you're not allowed to do so anyway
Atwater City Council votes for this they
vote to quote affirm the city's
commitment to fundamental constitutional
rights if we can permits it and you know
one defense of sanctuary cities I can't
believe I'm making a defense of
sanctuary cities but it is in this
aspect of the federal system that
the local arguing with the state arguing
with the federal and in those
disagreements and in those power
struggles our political traditions and
institutions and privileges and rights
are protected so I kind of get it I
still think the sanctuary cities should
be defunded they're still immoral
they're still wrong they're still
illegal but I understand why that
tension can be helpful so if it can be
helpful on a clear-cut issue a clearly
wrong issue such as illegal immigration
surely we can apply it to protecting our
most basic constitutional rights the
ability to leave our home the ability to
have an economy these are rights that we
were we were willing to go along with
people in the spirit of solidarity and
pandemic and police powers but that has
draw dragged on way it passed its
usefulness and nobody least of all the
people enforcing it and the labcoat
dictators that they're giving their
politics to can explain to us what the
whole point is so you've got great moves
from the cops in Camden New Jersey
you've got great moves from Atwater
California even President Trump himself
is calling the left's Bluff he made this
stunning announcement it shocked and
scandalized the press corps and the left
because he is showing us exactly what we
should be doing in our rebuffs against
the scientific dictators and against the
left we'll get to that a second first
though I've got to thank our friends
over at honey I've been using honey for
longer than there's been a Michael Nolt
show I've been using honey for longer
than there's been daily wire you know
when you go online and you're shopping
on the internet which I guess we're all
doing all the time now it's very
difficult to search for coupon codes
because you maybe you go you find a
coupon code then you go back doesn't
work that's - okay then you go back and
you can spend 20 minutes 25 minutes
trying to do this or more with honey the
coupons and savings come to you honey
it's free online shopping tool that
saves you money online it automatically
finds the best promo codes and applies
them to your cart which makes online
shopping finally feel as easy as it's
supposed to be I use this for everything
I use this when I buy flowers I use this
when I buy books I use this when I buy
clothing I mean I I can't remember the
last time I didn't use honey and
sometimes even if they can't get you a
promo code that gets you some bonus
points a little bit back it's just
amazing I mean I think the last time I
saved twenty five bucks last time I used
it and that's a regular occurrence so
not using honey is literally passing up
on free money it's free to use it
installs in just a few seconds plus it's
backed by PayPal so you know you can
trust it get honey for free at join
honey calm slash Knowles
that is join honey dot-com slash Knowles
canna wles Trump himself calling the
lefts bluff and he's doing it
specifically on this issue of
hydroxychloroquine you remember
hydroxychloroquine is this anti-malarial
drug that has shown promise
early on in treating coronavirus Trump
mentioned this and then because Trump
mentioned it the left had to come in and
say hydroxychloroquine is terrible and
then there's some study that shows that
it's not terribly effective even though
we have so little information right now
that it's very difficult to trust these
things especially when the lab coat
modelers have been so wrong about every
other aspect of this illness so
hydroxychloroquine it's been around for
a long time and president Trump mentions
offhandedly in a press briefing
yesterday that as a matter of fact he is
taking the drug himself to stave off the
corona virus you'd be surprised at how
many people are taken and especially the
frontline workers before you catch it
the frontline workers many many are
taking it I happen to be taking it I
happen to be taking it I drop C's over
Quinn wait right now yeah a couple of
weeks ago started taking it because I
think it's good I've heard a lot of good
stories and if it's not good I'll tell
you right I'm not going to get hurt by
it it's been around for 40 years for
malaria for lupus for other things I
take it frontline workers take it a lot
of doctors take excuse me a lot of
doctors take it I take it now I hope to
not be able to take it soon because you
know I hope they come up with some
answer
but I think people should be allowed to
this is exactly how to push back against
the media and the overreaching leftist
politicians now I'm not saying the way
to do it is to take hydroxychloroquine
I'm I'm I should differentiate between
those things
I'm saying the way to push back is to go
directly at their claims and with
responsibility and with precaution flout
those claims the alarmism from the left
and in this case the way Trump is doing
it is with this particular drug
hydroxychloroquine because comes out
says look we obviously don't have a
vaccine for this we might never have a
vaccine but there is this one drug it's
it's seems to be somewhat effective
doctors are saying that it's helped to
cure patients some patients say it saved
their lives they were on death's door
they took this drug and then all of a
sudden was great so so you know maybe
it's a good drug maybe we should try it
out and then simply because he said that
the left said all this drug it's gonna
kill everybody this is unproven the
drugs not unproven we've been using it
to treat malaria for well over 40 years
but the left doesn't care about that
they just have to contradict whatever
he's saying so then he he's so stubborn
like he's so ready to just smack down
whatever they're throwing at him but he
says I yeah I'm taking the drug I'm
taking you want it the proof of the
pudding is in the tasting okay you're
the media are trying to create this
hysteria to say that the drug is killing
people left and right Trump's a maniac
he's got blood on his hands he goes okay
well guess what I'm taking it myself and
look at me I'm fine he's doing fine the
headlines yesterday you you would have
thought this was the craziest that you
would have thought Trump is you know go
to a back alley buying buy and Roxy you
know and then chopping it up with a
credit card and blowing lines in the
White House rather than what actually
happened which is that this was
obviously prescribed to him by a doctor
not just any doctor the White House
doctor he's got the best scientific
experts in the world around him right
now
he's got doctor fowey he's got dr. Burks
he's got Mike Pence in a lab coat he's
got big experts okay and it is is it
going to kill him I hope not I don't I
don't think so though you know something
tells me that if it were first of all we
would know about it and - they wouldn't
have prescribed it for him
he's I really like when Trump does this
he is leading by example so Trump you
know he's taking this drug I don't know
whether the drug is gonna be effective
or not I don't know if it's gonna harm
him I suppose if it does they'll
probably take him off the drug some
people though were really scandalized by
this including the great Neil Cavuto I
love Neil Cavuto on Fox but he he took a
moment said hold on don't don't try this
at home kids those who took it in a
vulnerable population including those
with respiratory or other conditions
they died I want to stress again they
died if you are in a risky population
here and you are taking this as a
preventive treatment to ward off the
virus or in a worst case scenario you
are dealing with the virus and you are
in this vulnerable population it will
kill you I cannot stress enough this
will kill you so again whatever benefits
the president says this has and it
certainly has had for those suffering
from malaria dealing with lupus this is
a leap that should not be taken casually
by those wants to get home or assuming
well the president's says it's okay sure
it shouldn't be taken casually but
nobody should be prescribing themselves
drugs in the first place you know I mean
I see the point that Neil Cavuto is
making he's saying hey guys don't just
go out and start stuffing your faces
with that Roxie chloroquine fair enough
I nobody would disagree with him there
but I just don't think that's exactly
what people are doing the one story that
that the left-wing media was able to
find on this was that woman who fed her
husband fish tank cleaner and the more
and more you read about that story it
sounds a lot like she murdered him so I
don't know there I think there's an
investigation going on right now so this
just doesn't seem to be a big scourge of
course talk to your doctor before you
take any medication ask your doctor for
a prescription but I mean that is the
claim here right the the left is saying
you you will well the left end Neil
Cavuto I guess in this case saying you
will die if you take this and President
Trump is saying well guess we'll find
out it might be it might be a reckless
thing to do but that is the kind of
fearlessness that you're seeing from the
president not not just on the medical
front but much more importantly than
that on the media front
Nancy Pelosi was none too happy about
this Nancy Pelosi came out and not only
said that it was terrible for Trump to
take the hydroxychloroquine she also
called him fat as far as the president
is concerned the our producer president
and I would rather he not be taking
something that has not been approved by
the scientists especially in his age
group and in his shall we say weight
group had but it is morbidly obese they
say so
III think it was it's not a good idea
this is the most transparent concern
trolling ever I mean as though we're
supposed to believe that the Democrats
who called Donald Trump a Nazi fascist
racist bigot threat to humanity on earth
he's gonna he's gonna kill us all
whether through his response to the
pandemic or through global warming or or
by simply shocking and offending
everybody to death that they're really
seriously concerned that he might have
an adverse side effect from this
medicine I don't think so and then right
afterwards she calls him fat she body
shames the president I thought we were
told we can't body shame people imagine
if if a right winger said this sort of
thing about a democratic politician
maybe prominent Democratic politicians
that are around today obviously won't
name any names there would be an uproar
would be so offensive and be terrible
and yet for Trump there's nothing you
can't say about this guy there's nothing
too vile and disgusting to stay say
about this guy that you won't get credit
for so Democrats have very little to say
on this topic nothing that they've
predicted has come true nothing that
they've enacted has done any good even
the lockdowns I can't stress this point
enough there's no evidence that the
lockdowns have saved one single life the
point of the lockdown is to spread out
flatten the curve spread out the number
of cases so as not to overwhelm the
hospital system we never came close to
overwhelming hospital
system we had the Javits Center Hospital
empty in New York we had that hospital
ship empty in New York okay
never came close the only other reason
for the lockdowns is to buy time for a
vaccine which is nowhere in sight they
had some very promising vaccine in the
in the UK and then that that fizzled it
looks like it's not very promising at
all there are lots of viruses lots of
ailments that we don't have cures for
right so no reason to say that we'll
we'll be able to get one and and even if
we were in a year or 18 months and we
really gonna lock down our entire
society until then what would be the
effect of that they've got nothing on it
right so now they start changing their
tune with even just the littlest push
back you remember a few weeks ago at the
Andrew Cuomo the great hero of
coronavirus what a great leader he
should be the new Democratic nominee
never mind that he's been the most
incompetent governor in the entire
country on this issue never mind
that his state is doing the worst on
this issue and yet for some reason
they're saying that's evidence that that
the leader of that state needs to be
elevated and get a promotion
never mind that very specific policies
undertaken by Andrew Cuomo have killed
people never mind any of that Andrew
Cuomo said you know if all that they do
saves even one life than it will have
all been worth it that was a few weeks
ago today Andrew Cuomo is saying at a
press conference a lot of grannies are
gonna die here he is they're looking for
accountability and they feel that they
were failed what's what's the comment to
that yeah the comment is this and I have
those conversations all day long with
people who've lost people right we lost
139 people yesterday in hospitals who is
accountable for those 139 deaths well
how do we get justice for those families
who had 139 deaths what is justice who
can we prosecute for those deaths nobody
nobody
mother nature God where did this virus
come from people are going to die by
this virus that is the truth
older people vulnerable people are going
to die from this virus that is going to
happen okay well that's a it's a little
different tune than we were hearing a
few weeks ago isn't it if everything we
do saves even one life it will be worth
it older people are going to die they're
gonna die
Cait get around death well isn't that
the point we were making isn't the point
we were making that mortality is a fact
in epidemics mortality is a an even more
urgent fact and you can't always stop
that you can't always even slow it down
and the policies that you undertake
might have negative consequences might
kill more people my damage Society might
damage their lives that was the point we
were making and then you demagogued the
issue and said that we wanted to kill
granny and we had blood on our hands and
we were heartless and only you cared
about saving even one life and but now
you're telling us that a lot of grannies
are gonna die I also love the way he
opens up the clip who can be blamed for
all these deaths what is justice wow
really poetical stuff Governor Cuomo you
actually for some of them at least you
you can be blamed for some of those
deaths because just to quote one policy
you took sick people and put them into
nursing homes during the lockdown and
when you take sick people and you put
them into nursing homes thousands and
thousands of people died because the
virus it's this isn't a business and
brain surgery you don't need to be the
exalted doctor fowey His Eminence the
smartest man in the world to realize
that when you take people who are sick
with a highly contagious virus and then
you put them with the most vulnerable
population for that virus then more
people are gonna die and yet that's
exactly what Andrew Cuomo did he's
catching a lot of heat for it right now
and so all of a sudden he's deflecting
all responsibility whatsoever even
though a few weeks ago he said his
policies were gonna have a real effect
there you know if they save one life
they're all worth it well what happens
if they accidentally kill thousands of
people no we can't be held responsible
some people are gonna die Yeah right you
probably should have listened to this
podcast and many other shows many many
other people on the right
earlier on rather than just try to
vilify all of us as being callous and
uncaring about human life and ready to
throw granny off a cliff cos because
none of that happened just push back on
them they will fold
they are folding I was down in San Diego
last weekend down there visiting some
friends and that we go out for a little
walk on the street there are people out
milling about so I'm walking just a few
of us you know we're walking down a
sidewalk and some woman some Karen this
is the this is the new term Karen or one
of these sort of women generally I guess
white women who yell at everybody and
tell everybody what to do and you know
make a big nuisance this woman who would
fit the description of a Karen is
walking down the street walking her dog
I don't have a mask on she doesn't have
a mask on and she starts yelling at us
says what what are you doing what i what
am i swear you talking about well what
what are you what why are you walking
you can't walk there said where would
you like us to walk
I don't know away from me and she's kind
of coming to in that meanwhile she's
doing exactly the same thing that we're
doing on the sidewalk I guess she just
owns the sidewalk it's it is offensive
to her that anybody should be should be
out at all because you know human or her
fellow human beings her fellow citizens
are nothing but carriers of this disease
and pestilence she actually sort of like
jumps off of the sidewalk as she's
yelling at us with her two dogs so that
she doesn't get infected by us now what
would have happened is she'd walked
right by us in the fresh air in the
sunshine with no masks on you know what
would have happened nothing nothing at
all would have happened she would've
been fine I guess we still would have
had that unpleasant interaction but
would have been absolutely fine and this
this woman I saw in in San Diego was not
the only one who was doing this there's
a Karen who's gotten very very famous
around the country we will get to her in
one second first I got to thank our
friends over at light stream you know
right now saving every single penny that
you possibly can is particularly
important including on your credit card
balance right now you can get a rate as
low as five point nine five percent APR
with Auto pay much lower than the
national average credit card rate of
over 19% APR there are absolutely no
fees the application is quick and easy
and is 100% online light stream believes
that people with good credit deserve a
better loan experience and that's
exactly what they deliver people love
light stream here's what this customer
had to say say quote I heard about live
stream on a podcast and was able to look
on the website and get clearer
information the application process was
quick and easy and you hear a lot of
reactions like that this is a great
opportunity to solve your credit card
debt problem you know especially in
times like this where it really really
matters let's not forget that crises can
breed opportunity apply today to get a
special interest rate discount and save
even more the only way to get this
discount is to go to light stream comm /
Knowles lig HT s TR e am calm / Knowles
subject credit approval rate includes
0.50% auto pay discount terms and
conditions applying office you're
subject to change without notice visit
light stream that comes lash Knowles
for more information so my Karen in San
Diego was not the only Karen around here
is a woman walking around a beach
yelling at people for not having masks
on at the beach oh my god not one person
with a mask on everybody is here nobody
look at all those people there's like 20
people hi I'm Rebecca brown and I'm
flipping out because governor Newsom
announced at this Friday we are no
longer gonna be on total lockdown
we're opening back up I'm flipping out
because people haven't been wearing
masks and this is gonna be even more
loosey-goosey than ever before I think
it's all gonna go downhill from this
point on so I couldn't tell if this was
a joke or not when I saw it when I
initially saw this I thought okay this
is what it's got to be a parody or
something of all these people who become
so hysterical that they would want you
to wear a giant mask even when you're on
the beach
in the sunshine it's far far away from
people and then I met that woman in San
Diego and I realized no some people are
really really hysterical about this the
way to push back against I talked to
friends of mine relatives of mine who
have been locked in doors this whole
time they really have barely gone
outside even though they're not
particularly vulnerable even though
they're not really in the at-risk
population and they've done it because
of the doomsday models because of the
people in the media and in elected
office and the experts and lab coats
who've told them that they're gonna die
if they walk outside I understand why
some people feel that kind of fear I
mean the the entire liberal apparatus
has done everything they can to gin up
that fear the best way to deflate that
kind of alarmism just act normal keep
calm and carry on you know they're gonna
try to shut down your gym even at 20
percent capacity even with the fever
guns even with the masks just open the
gym just go to gym just work out they're
gonna tell you that any if you get the
virus you're gonna die and if you take
the medicine for the virus you're gonna
die
well maybe the President of the United
States can lead the way and say look my
doctor prescribed me this medicine and
I'm not dying doesn't mean you should
all go out and do this drug immediately
but it does mean that this situation is
not as deadly and and dire and
catastrophic as all of the so-called
experts told us was for weeks and weeks
just go out when you're when you're
walking by somebody on a beach just
don't don't have the mask on on the
beach be responsible be respectful but
don't indulge the fantasies and
delusions and power grabs of people who
have been wrong this entire time a lot
more to get to we've got to get to one
of the negative effects of the virus we
got to get to the coronavirus class
divided and we got to get to how the
left dumped believe all women because
now this is getting really Orwellian
we're being told by the New York Times
that believe all women is a right wing
trap news to me
the me2 movement is a super secret for
DHS level right wing trap oh my god
Cavanaugh Cavanaugh was actually behind
it the whole time region what a great
trick we played first though I've got to
thank you I want to thank you for tuning
in and being memberís you know and it's
time to share some good news with you
the double tumbler is back but it's only
available for our most exclusive
membership tier all access you get a lot
with all access three more hours of
bench P or three total hours not three
more hours of the bench Bureau show
exclusive Q&A is the new all-access Live
and double the tumblers you get the one
where is it do I have a second I do have
a second Wow look at this look at this
we maybe will do the Karen addition and
get three tumblers I don't know that
would be too crazy we have two tumblers
right now but that's for all access head
on over to daily wire comm slash
subscribe to join all access and get 15%
off with coupon code Knowles right now
so head on over daily wire comm slash
subscribe see you there we'll be right
back with a lot more
every day the unintended negative
consequences of this lockdown become
clearer and clearer one of which is so
ironic we're told that we need to all
stay in place and not do anything until
we find a vaccine which might be an
imaginary vaccine because there are
plenty of illnesses that we don't have
vaccines for and there's no evidence
that we're ever going to get one for the
coronavirus right so we're all that we
have to stay in place until we get the
vaccine the vaccine is the most
important thing well do you know one of
the consequences of us waiting and
waiting on this vaccine kids aren't
getting their vaccines there because
we're waiting on an imaginary vaccine
kids are not getting the vaccines for
the real things right now the number of
childhood vaccines administered in
Michigan this is according to a report
that was released by the CDC has dropped
by as much as 22 percent amid the corona
virus pandemic obviously there are a lot
of other things that are going on right
now two things that you know I guess you
would call elective I guess you'd call
these vaccines elective that normally
would be taking place or not taking
place so our a real life health care
apparatus that we've built up over 100
200 years that is being neglected for
the imaginary healthcare apparatus of a
completely empty Javits Center in New
York and of a vaccine that doesn't exist
yet and of the health care workers who
are being laid off right now they're
being furloughed because everything else
has been shut down there's a real real
irony to that of course an irony that I
think the left is beginning to see
righty-oh Cuomo is is now changing his
tune obviously and yet even though the
left can now see they were wrong about
everything they double down it's it's
like that governor in New Jersey he says
these aren't just words we're gonna come
back tomorrow I'm serious you better not
stop us tomorrow they feel threatened
they feel defensive because because
everything has gone so haywire and
people are no longer listening to them
that's fine I think the politicians
right now are completely on the ropes
I think we need to keep absolutely
pummeling them with these facts with
these observations about what is going
on as a result of the lock downs and
then most importantly we need to ignore
them I mean even the Marxists can get
behind reopening even the Bernie bros
are starting to get behind reopening
there's this sort of irony with the the
lockdown that I haven't heard other
people talking about but I think it's
actually exacerbating a lot of tensions
going on right now which is that the
lockdown is seriously exacerbating class
divides you know I don't usually talk in
terms of these this kind of Marx history
of the world of the class struggle and
all of that I don't think that's really
the most important way to view the world
but the left talks about that a lot and
if anything has exacerbated class
tensions is this lockdown I'll give you
an example of this I've noticed as I go
into retail shops or something that the
workers there more often than not are
unpleasant compared to before the
lockdown when everyone's basically
perfectly pleasant but since the
lockdown
I've had several rude interactions with
retail workers which doesn't make sense
to me I'm so wonderfully Pleasant I'm so
wonderfully amiable that I certainly
couldn't have done anything I've done
but really my behavior has not changed
there there has been something that's
going on and I kind of get it
I actually I empathize with the retail
workers which is that everybody is being
told this hysteria from the left and the
media that if you so much as go outside
you're gonna die right you've got to
work you work from home safer at home
stay at home oh except for you little
pesky retail workers you come on in you
sacrifice your lives so that we can go
buy our almond milk but all all the
really fancy people who have jobs where
you can work from home they're gonna
work from home because their lives
matter but your life doesn't matter I
get it I'd be irritated too if I were a
real toy worker it doesn't matter of
course that the alarmism that the left
is peddling isn't true right I mean
there you're not going to die the minute
that you walk out the door
especially if you're in a not a
particularly at-risk population the very
fact that you're being told that means
that you're being told yeah you're
expendable grocery store worker you're
expendable barista because I got to get
my latte you know the those people who
are working from home to protect their
lives they need to get their lattes so
you need to go in and risk your lives
that's not a very nice thing to tell
people the alternative to this is what
the right is saying which is that
nobody's expendable
and nobody is non-essential everybody is
essential in the economy everybody okay
and a world in which we say that a huge
portion of workers are non-essential or
that only they're really fancy people
with the fancy jobs only they get to
work from home protect their lives
that's an ugly society that's a that's a
tense society that's one that that that
views people as unimportant I mean
that's ironically that's what Andrew
Cuomo was saying early on he says if we
save one life well you know put that
into practice if you really view human
beings as dignified then you know treat
them with a little bit of dignity treat
everybody as essential be all in it
together I unbelievable political times
we're living in that it's actually the
right who's who's defending the Marxists
I don't know I don't know how we how we
got to this spot even crazier even more
backwards we are now to spot where
believe all women let me to movement is
actually a right-wing trap so the the
left is in a really bad spot the
feminist movement in a very bad spot
because the feminists told us during
BRIC the Brett Kavanaugh hearings that
any time any woman makes an accusation
no matter how outlandish no matter how
uncorroborated no matter how much it
changes we have to believe those women
we need to strip men of due process
rights and we need to destroy their
careers all right there was no evidence
that Breck havin aw did anything
untoward to that lady
Christine Ford no evidence that
Christine Ford ever met wreck Cavanaugh
she couldn't tell us when the alleged
incident took place who was there in the
room how many people were there where it
was the one friend
she said was around at the time said it
didn't happen she changed her story she
got caught in a bunch of lies right she
was completely uncredible then there was
another lady who was somehow even less
credible Julie sweat Nick who said that
Brett Kavanaugh was a gang rapist an
immediate Jake Tapper oh they were
promoting this woman they were promoting
all this trash and they said if you
didn't believe these women then you were
some some monster now of course Joe
Biden has much more credible allegations
against him and all of a sudden they're
saying now we shouldn't believe that
woman so Susan Faludi
who is a journalist writing the New York
Times she says believe all women is
right-wing trap Joe Biden has been
accused of sexual assaulting
conservatives are having a field day oh
we're having a field day no we're just
holding you to your own standards
exalting that they've caught feminists
in a new hypocrisy trap a woman with no
corroboration beyond contemporaneous
accounts charge is a powerful man with a
decades-old crime hmm doesn't that sound
mighty close to Christine Blasi for its
complaint against Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh no it doesn't actually
because the woman who's alleging the the
crime against Joe Biden has
contemporaneous corroboration and
Christine Ford didn't so actually it's
not this one seems a whole lot more
credible than Christine Ford even though
you're not believing this lady because
it's politically inconvenient for you
anyway hey doesn't that sound mighty
close to christine ford yes this time
many liberals who've championed the me2
movement seem skeptical gotcha but in
fact believe all women does have an
asterisk it's never been feminist
boilerplate well we are witnessing is
another instance of the right to crying
what it imagines to be the American
women's movement spend some mind-numbing
hours tracking the origins of believe
all women on social media sites and news
databases as I did and you'll discover
how language like a virus can mutate
overnight all of a sudden yesterday's
quotes suffer the insertion of some
foreign DNA that makes them easy to
weaponize in this case that intrusion
that foreign intrusion is a word all all
insertion was all the rage during the
Cavanagh hearing so they're saying
actually the phrase was believe women
not believe all women
it's conservatives who added the all to
it and that totally changes the meaning
except that isn't true
that's the that's the big problem the
women's March we eat it out we believe
all survivors kirsten gillibrand tweeted
out do we value women do we believe
women do we give them the opportunity to
tell their story to be heard will we
ensure that they get the justice they
deserve we must fight to be a country
that answers yes every time every time
Hillary Clinton this one the most ironic
every survivor of sexual assault
deserves to be heard believed and
supported everyone except for the ones
that Hillary Clinton spent decades
smearing I guess but everyone actually
the Hillary Clinton part is is important
to remember here the left has always
been hypocritical on feminism all the
way back all the way back to the 90s all
the way before that feminism has never
been a tool to help women and treat
women fairly and apply standards equally
no it's just a political instrument for
attacking Republicans and not attacking
Democrats going easy on Democrats we can
go back and tap we can Google this we
can see that they're lying to us
now even the idea by the way that
believe all women is different than
believe women what's the difference if
there's no difference at all if you say
believe women as a categorical statement
that is exactly the same as saying
believe all women you could say believe
some women I guess that would be the
alternative but obviously none of the
left ever said that they believe women
believe all women it's exactly the same
thing and beyond that they actually they
actually said believe all women before
this is not the only way the left rest
of manipulate language before we go I've
got to get to this is my favorite story
probably the entire day the UN UN tweets
that they say what you say matters help
create a more equal world by using
gender-neutral language if you're
unaware about someone's gender or are
referring to a
root UN Women org hashtag generation
equality they have all these words that
were not allowed to say anymore and now
these words that we have to say instead
if you don't know someone's gender use
the gender-neutral language so you can't
say mankind you have to say humankind
even though man is a gender-neutral
pronoun even though in in the beginning
God created man both male and female he
created them you have to say humankind
well done that doesn't work so the
problem is that you've got man in here
on mankind but you've also got man in
there on humankind so it should be Hugh
person kind right but but wait a sec
it's you person kind that still has Sun
in it doesn't she can't said that sexist
that's not equality so it should be
super daughter super daughter kind she
okay guess you can say super daughter
kind instead of Chairman you have to say
chair so you have to replace a person
with a piece of piece of furniture that
makes sense
instead of congressman you have to say
legislature doesn't really differentiate
between all the different legislators
fine it's turn a businessman
you have to say representative those
actually don't mean the same thing
representative means congressman not
businessman okay it's alright I don't
expect them to know a lot about language
policeman you gotta say police officer
landlord you have to say owner
boyfriend/girlfriend you got to say
partner you know as though you're about
to like open an accounting office with
somebody instead of have a love affair
with them salesman you got to say sales
person obviously gotta be sales /
daughter you know that manpower is
workforce workforce not manpower made a
name family name fireman firefighter
husband or wife you have to say spouse
no no I don't think I'm gonna do any of
that the what is the purpose of the
United Nations what is the I guess it's
supposed to provide a forum to discuss
international issues and basically just
give the United States a way to wrangle
a bunch of countries in the world that's
how it's supposed to work theoretically
that's not how it really works way the
UN really works is we give them plush
real estate in New York we invite the
worst people on earth to come over here
and criticize us without any any
credibility these are the work
people on the planet they criticize us
then the important initiatives that the
UN undertakes is to try to destroy the
English language with a bunch of stupid
euphemisms to push left-wing feminism
let's just not do it
obviously we shouldn't use this kind of
language we shouldn't fund this kind of
organization we shouldn't pretend okay
we shouldn't go along with this this has
been a theme of the past certainly the
best week really we've been talking
about it for the past several weeks
we're in a different political moment
now than we were in four or five years
ago okay the four or five years ago kind
of conservative vision in America was
lose nicely hey you know be a Mitt
Romney make some weak argument and then
lose but lose really nicely you know
play your role as the court jester and
the kingdom of liberalism and then lose
really nicely and and that's fine don't
really attack anybody too hard yeah we
know the media is against you but that's
life we know the education systems
against you aw shucks what can you do
we know that virtually every institution
in this country is left-wing progressive
whatever you want but hey that's just
the way it is can't push back no I think
we can pretty sure we can that's the
defining feature of the Trump era that's
why the Trump air isn't so nice and
genial is because he's actually doing
something so let's do it let's not go
along with this anymore let's just
defund the damn thing how about that how
about we call all of their Bluffs and
watch them fold I think I think that's
the only way that we're gonna shake
ourselves out of this madness cultural
political locked in our apartments
wearing masks on a sunny beach just push
back just call their bluff they have a
whole lot less power than they pretend
that they do that's our show I'm Michael
Knowles's the Michael Nolt show we'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
fenders hair and makeup Nika Geneva
production assistant Ryan love the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and he can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there